よろしくお願いします dīghā
jāgarato ratti, dīghaṃ santassa yojanaṃ. Dīgho bālanas
aṃsāro, saddhammaṃ avijānataṃ.
という経です dīghā
jāgarato ratti, dīghaṃ santassa yojanaṃ. Dīgho bālanas
aṃsāro, saddhammaṃ avijānataṃ.
それは五番目 このBālavaggaという風な名前で bāla
っていうのは一応あまり智慧がないという意味なんですね
一応タイトルつける場合は
ただこの偈文の中で出てくる一つの単語を選んでるだけなんですね
ですから あまり内容を示しているわけでもないんです bāla
という言葉はいくつかの偈で出てくるんですが
それで意味を説明しますけど dīghā
jāgarato ratti dīghā
っていうのは長いということで jāgarato
っていうのは徹夜する人でしょうかね
寝ないで徹夜している人ということで
その人にratti 夜は長いんだよと
徹夜する人には夜は長いんだと
次はdīghaṃ santassa yojanaṃ santassa
っていうのは疲れている人ですね
疲れている人に yojanaṃ
っていうのは距離を測るもので
どれぐらい長いかっていうことはちょっとわからないんですけど
昔中国で里という尺度がありましたね
一里 三里とかね この一里ってどれぐらい長いかっていうこと
まだそれは私はわかりませんけど
そんなような感じで 昔のそれなりの距離を示す単語で
現代風に言えば一キロ
一キロメートルぐらいような感覚で理解すればいいと思います
それで知っている人々はそこら辺で研究なさって
明確にヨジュンっていうのは何メートル
何センチ 何ミリでしょうかっていうことを調べればよろしいし
一応私は一般的にただ昔の距離を測るときの尺度
それで一ヨジュンというかね
ヨジュンっていうのは何かそのまま日本訳にしてヨジュンとかなんとか言いますからね
一キロぐらいも疲れている人にとってはかなり長いということなんです
そのように三行目 dīgho
bālanasaṃsāro
無知な人に輪廻も長いんだよと
理由はsaddhammaṃ avijānataṃ
真理は知らないからなんですね
それでそんな意味ですよ
別に説明するところはないと思いますけどね
[音楽]もう一度まとめてみようというとね
まあ夜寝ないでいる人にとっては夜は長くて長くてね
こんなに長いのかっていう
疲れている人にはね 一キロっていうのはえらい長くて
もう歩けないと どうしようもないってことになるんです
で 真理を知らない人にとっても
輪廻もそういうふうな感じで
すごい長いんだと なかなか解脱は得られないんだっていう
何か言いたいことがございますかね
それについて 説明は終わり
よろしいですか 輪廻は長いって言っても
うんざりしたっていう気分の長さだったらもううんざりだっていう風になるんじゃないでしょうか
だから長いって言っても
だから例えば疲れてる人に道が遠いって言ったら
もう長くてうんざりで
もう歩きたくないっていう気分になるわけですよね
それと同じようなニュアンスで
どうしてその輪廻が長いというふうに言うんですか？そのもう長くてうんざりだと思います
やめますっていう  疲れている人はもううんざりで歩かないでしょう
一キロ先に行かなくちゃいけないんだけど
行かないんです 座り込んでいるんです
ちょこっと一キロ行けば
あそこにすごい面白いものあるのに
行かないんです だからちょこっと真理知れば
そこで究極な幸福 解脱あるのにやらないんですね
さらに  先生 よろしいですか
このサッダーなんつーのは
あのサッダーダンマンとなってますよね
これはダンマンとサッダーと区別ってるわけですか
あの まあもう聖なる教えということですね
サッダンマといえばブッダの教えっていうことにはまあね
制限されます ただ ダンマといえば物事にもダンマと呼ぶんですね
物事 すべてのものにもダンマというんですね
だからそういうふうな意味ではなくて
これはブッダが説かれた真理だよっていうことをはっきりするためにサッということを入れますけど
まあだいたい芸の中だからね
いろいろ文字の長さとかいろいろ計算しなくちゃいけないんだから
まあそういう場合もありますけど
一応この場合はね しっかりと仏陀の教えということで
よろしいですか えーと
あの ものすごい長い長いエピソードがありますけど
まあそれ私はあまり物語を語るのはそれほど上手じゃないんだから
まあそこは皆様ご自分で勉強して
このストーリーをね 理解した方がいいと思いますけどね
で 輪廻長いっていうことはね
すごい長いんですけどね
まあ一般的な仏教ではね
まあ劫年で計算するんだだからこの百年万年ではなくて
まあ劫年というかね 劫というかね
年とは言わないんですけどね
で 一劫二劫三劫と まあ劫っていうのはすごい長い時間なんですね
だからあの数字では阿僧祇劫っていう数字があります
これはもうおそらく あの
十の百八十価 もうそこらもっとかなぐらいの数字なんですけど
それは普通の数学で阿僧祇劫っていうのは一番上の頭の中で計算できる一番大きい数字として取ってます
阿僧祇劫って 阿僧祇劫の直訳は
あの リジストで リジツ
何でしたっけ？リジツ
桁  桁でね まあ桁数ではちょっともう重すぎ多すぎやと数えられないんだ
例えば十の百八十乗といえばね
結構桁にしちゃうとね
困ったもんですからね
でもまあそこまでは一応昔は計算はしていたんです
それでも足らなくて まあ仏教のテキストになってくると
まあ劫という数字 言葉使うんですね
で 劫っていうのは数字じゃないんですね
ただ もうもうだいたい劫の説明する場合は
もう一つの世界が現れて消えるということなんですね
だから まあもう太陽が現れて太陽が消えてしまうぐらいの時間ぐらいに感じた方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
だからはっきりした数字じゃないんですね
その場合は 一劫の太陽が現れてきて
また惑星が出てきて 生命も誕生して
それでやがてもう太陽が破壊して
そのシステムが壊れてしまう
それが一で 一劫というふうに考えるんです
だから どんな太陽の寿命もぴったし同じってわけじゃないんです
太陽の寿命はそれぞれバラバラなんですけど
だから数字じゃないんです
数字といえば この阿僧祇劫っていうのははっきりした数字で
それ以後以上大きい数字は使ってなかったんです
阿僧祇劫はもうチャートがありまして
もうこれ計算してみればもうわかるんですね
まあ十百 もうなんとかなんとかとかね
一千十万 もう一兆なんとかありまして
それでも十の百八十乗ぐらいのところまで百八十価っていうことははっきりは覚えてないんですけど
まあそれぐらいでももう数字は終わりと
終わりではなくて まあ人間の能力で計算できるところは
まあそんな程度やっててやってますね
それ以上はもう数えられないということにしているんですね
で まあそれは数字ではっきりした
劫っていうのははっきり数字ではないんです
時間なんですね それで輪廻の場合はその劫で数えるんですね
もう百劫ぐらい地獄にいたんだとかね
もうあるいはこの阿僧祇劫というと
まあそれぐらいの劫が地獄に落ちちゃっていたとかね
そうすると信じられないぐらい長くなるんですね
阿僧祇劫といっても もうものすごい長い数字で
それぐらいの劫で数えちゃうとね
それぐらいのものね 地獄
とにかくもう人間にはどうしても想像すること
イメージすることも全くも不可能な長い長い時間なんですね
それで輪廻っていうのは
まあ時間的にはもう定められてないんです
もうずっともう悟ってない限りは
もう輪廻はする で 真理発見したらそれで悟るんですね
それで輪廻から脱出する
輪廻を脱出するんですね
ですから 輪廻は無限という単語を使わないんです
無限と言えば終わりがないっていうことだから
で そういう単語を使う場合は
すごく微妙に神経使ってます
仏教では 輪廻は無限やと言うと悟りが不可能になっちゃうし
もうもうすぐもう二 三週間頑張れば悟りますよと言ってるんだからね
だからえらくバカにしてるんですよ
この瞑想方法とかブッダの道とかね
で バカにして まあそれはすごいありがたいことで
バカになるの誰かっていうことははっきり言ってますからね
で そこでこのチャンス逃しちゃってね
まあ教えをバカにして
まあいろいろいい加減わがまま
自分の 私のやり方でやるぞという態度でしょ
もう大体ほとんど まあ大体ね
まあ 二十人に瞑想教えたら
まあ 十九人はもう大体私のやり方でやるんだと
すごい頭がいいんですよ
決して言う通りにはやらない
二十人じゃなくて 私の実際の例で言えば
まあ 百人に一人もないんです
素直に私言う通りにやる人っていうのは
お前いうこと聞いてやるもんかと
いう条件で 自分で考えてやってます
で 私もそんな立場がないんだからね
身分がもうあまりにも低いんだから
あまり言うこと言えないんだから黙ってはいるんです
黙って見ていて 私の頭の中では
いてもいなくてもどうでもいい存在で
気にもしない よく理解していると思ってますけどね
そうないんです 体の周りグラグラグラグラ回っていたってもね
もう存在しないんです
もう 百人に一人だけでも
言う通りにやる人のことはもうしっかりと教えてるんです
これもしょうがないんですよ
まあそんな  くだらんことをね
頑張る日よりはね 寝た方が楽だからね
それだったら私は寝る
あの ヒナリくんと投げる
その方が楽しいんです
無知な人のことを考えるよりはね
だから私のやり方でやるっていうことはね
自分がブッダよりも頭が優れてるという言葉で
ことでしょ？だからまあ助けられませんね
私はあれは勉強してる
これは勉強してる そうではないか
ああではないかとか じゃあどうするかっていうことくださいと
それで助けることは確実に自分で不可能にしているんです
で そうでないと お釈迦様おっしゃってる通りに
そことは本当に本当に心配なんですよ
[笑い]で まあただ単にこの幻想に対する執着をしているだけのことです
で そんなにすごいことではないんです
で まあブッダの時代ならね
そんなにわずかなもうもう幼稚園にも行ったことがない
まあ子供さえもね 悟り開いたんだからね
ただ言うことを素直に聞くだけで
お釈迦様にしても言うことを素直に聞けない人っていうのは育てられなかったんですね
あんたそう言っても 私はこう思ってるんだよと
知識的に疑問を出しちゃうと
それはもう知識的にあんたそう思う理由はなんでしょうかとか
なんとか話し合って それで知識人なら自分の考え方が間違っていると分かったら
ああ やっぱり間違っていたねとかね
それでも解決するんですからね
だから知識人に対する反論にケチつけてるわけじゃないんです
知識人が理解して理解していくんだ
自身が知りたいんだから
わざと攻撃する 本当のこと何だと自分で知りたいんだから
あえていろいろ反論出したり攻撃したりして
で それっていうのはよく分かりますよ
で 正直な疑問ですからね
それで特にこの質問しない人っていうのはすごい頑固でね
絶対聞いてやらないっていう態度もあるし
自分の気持ちだけは変えませんよと
だからそういうことで
人間っていうのはね どうせ矛盾ですからね
自分の思考でよろしければね
勝手にすればいいでしょうしね
あっちこっち行ったり
勉強したり 苦しんだりする必要ないでしょうし
だからいろんなところに行って勉強したりする
みんなに迷惑なんです
一切勉強したくないんでしょうし
勉強したくない人に限って
あちらもこちらも行くんですね
だから まあかなり社会にとって
社会に対してはすごい迷惑というかね
まあ汚染ですね これは激しい社会に対する自信破壊です
これもまあお釈迦様もすごいもう嫌な気分でいただなと思いますよ
ある日 こういうコナッチダンマパダにもありますからね
頭の悪いやつらがスープの中にあるサジのようなもんだよと
スープを作る場合はもうサジでかき混ぜたりするでしょうね
ずーっと だからスープの中に入り込んでいるんですよ
スープを水と材料を入れた時点からもう
しかし味がわからないんだと
それぐらい愚か者はそんなもんやと
いくら聞いても聞いてもスープの中にあるサジみたいだ
だからこれ私が文句言うよりはえらいすごく厳しいんですよ
ブッダの言葉っていうのは
ちょっと知恵のある人
頭のいい人の場合は 舌に一滴のスープを入れたみたいなもんだと
ちょこっと一滴でも舌に入れたらどんな味かわかるでしょうに
だから一滴でわかる この味は
あのサジはスープの釜の中にいるのにわからないという
だからこの若道を自分の考え方でやるぞっていうことはね
そういうもので もうお釈迦様にしたっても
どうにもどうすることもできないことなんです
それはそれで だから頑張ってください
そういうふうに それはいいんだけど
輪廻っていうのはもうそういう遊びじゃなくて
すごく長いもんなんですよ
一劫と言っても 私たちには想像できる長さじゃないんです
だから 例えば今人間で生まれていて
また再び人間になるということはね
これ何劫たつかわからないんでしょうね
宇宙ではいろんな太陽が現れたり
惑星が現れたりするかもしれませんだけど
このちょうどいい条件で
ちょうどいい条件で 人間のレベルみたいなところになって
また修行できるというのは
これね ほとんどもう 考えられないんですよ
だから定次元でいるのはすごい簡単なんです
だから地獄に落ちたら
地獄っていうのはこのキリスト教の地獄しか皆様経験ないかもしれませんだけど
仏教の地獄っていうのはもう単語だけ借りてるんであって
これまたすごい複雑ですからね
いわゆる自分の意志で自分を開発できないという
悲しい生命のことを言ってるんですよ
人間っていうのは 色いろいろ苦労があっても
自分で自分を開発することできるんですよ
だから 不自由 不自由 不自由
不自由でありながら この
なんとか逃げて脱出するというかね
脱走することもできるんですね
ほとんどの生命には もう不自由であっても脱走不可能状態に閉じ込められているんですね
例えば猫を見たってもう世の中人間の社会でいるんですけど
脱走できないんですよ
あの知識次元をね 全くも変えることはできないんです
また何か頑張ってみようかなと言っても
寿命短いんだからね もう早く死んじゃうでしょう
で まあ地獄っていうのは猫も地獄なんですよ
犬も地獄にいるんです
だからこの人間が味わっ
人間に与えられているこの頑張れば脱走できるんだよと
刑務所にいるのはいるんだけど
もうそこそこいくらでも隙間がありますよと
だから脱走するんだから
そうか 堂々と胸を張ってね
もう玄関から正面玄関から出ていくことはできないかもしれませんよ
だからバカだからそう思ってるんだよ
どうもどうも じゃあ私はこれから脱走しますよと
じゃあお世話になりましたとかね
みんなに握手をして それはできないんだけどね
どうせ脱走は脱走だから
それなりに頭を使って
もう環境はすごくスタディをして
もう警備の人々は警備は甘いんだからね
それでも何時に来るかとかね
それそことスタディをして
あいつはすごい厳しいんだけど
もうもうテレビつけちゃうと
もう部屋から出てこないんだそうとか
この時間やとかね 穴掘るなりに何でもあるのとか
その番組はもう三十五分で終わりますから
終わった途端 こいつはまた周り周り回りますからね
その間でやらなくちゃいけないかとかね
そういういろいろ工夫しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからそのチャンスはない次元はすべて地獄に据えているんです
だから生命っていうのはストップはしない
ずっとどこかで生まれ変わる
どこかで生まれ変わるといえば
宇宙の我々知っている範囲で調べたっても
人間らしき生命っていうのはいまだに科学者は見つけてないでしょ
生命らしきものは だから
地獄にいるチャンスっていうのはいくらでもあるんです
[笑い]人間ぐらいの生命は宇宙の至る所にいるんだっていうのは仏教では言ってはいるんだけど
それは仏教の話で 科学者が言わない限りは誰も真実だと認めないでしょうに
科学者にとってはまだ月のところもまだわからないんですね
二 三ヶ月間いたわけでもないんだからね
だからそれが最高の知識レベルだからね
仏教でいういろんなところでも生命がいて
釈尊が時々そちらにも説法したんだぞというね
大きな大々説法会だったら
それをみんなに聞こえるようにしていたんだとかね
で 銀河銀河放送で で 当然あの音だけじゃなくて
お釈迦様の姿まで見えているんだと
だからそのその惑星の生命がやっぱり自分の国に来て喋ってるんだと
本当はとかね そういう風にまでそこまでリアルでで
話を聞いていたんだという話もあることはあるんだけど
まあそれはどこまでどうかというのは私はわかりませんし
まあ論理的に言えば こんな広い宇宙でね
いくらなんでもいくらでもあり得るっていうことはね
それだけは我々の現代科学知識から推測だけはできる
ただ 私たちはこの惑星の範囲からは出ることはできないだけのことです
だから人間みたいな次元で生まれ変われるっていうことは
もうほとんど無理というぐらいの不可能なことで
で 他の地獄のレベルではいくらでもいられます
だからずっと輪廻をしながらしながらしながらしながらはいるんですよ
だからそれはこう単位で数えなくちゃいけない
これはもう 100万劫とかね
例えば地獄に落ちたら
それはまあ じゃあまあ 1万劫
10万劫でまあなんとかなるでしょうとかね
仏教から見れば別に普通ですよ
それが 一旦地獄に落ちたら
もうもうこの地球は自分がいた場所っていうのはもうすぐもう破壊するでしょうし
また現れるチャンスっていうのはね
ないんだから もう 100万劫ぐらい地獄にいたっていうのは
これはすごいもう短いんですね
だからあの阿僧祇劫ぐらいいたんだとかね
というのは まあ普通なんです
それっていうのは だから輪廻の長さっていうのはすごいことなんですよ
それで輪廻長い間でいられるんだからね
大変喜んだ方がいいんですね
だからみんな決して輪廻だけは脱出しないというね
覚悟をしているでしょうね
覚悟しなくてもいい 別に脱出できんだからね
こんなレベルでは 例えば日本でブッダのカードいっぱいあるでしょうね
あれを見てみると もうものすごいブッダを侮辱していますよ
偉大なるテスカさんでしたってもね
自分が誰よりも知っているようなつもりで書いてますよ
仏教の人は誰よりも それには日本人文句言うのはわかりますけど
もう右左にわからないんだからね
知ってる我々でも見たって別にいいや
もうどうせバカだからっていうことでね
どうせ知ってるわけじゃないんだぞと
あのブッダという あのなんかあの映画あったでしょ
あのリトルブッダというね
すごい世界的な人気があって
仏教の根本真理に反していますよ
あの映画は 仏教というのをなんとなく何でしたっけね
あのアニメ様だと思ってるんですかね
例の話やらなんだから
なんだらかんだらとかね
それぐらいのもうアホな知識で書いて
もう仏教の国にまで見せたら
仏教徒が全然するのに
別にまあまあどうせそんな程度でしょうと
ただ金儲かるかないかと
だからもうもう誰かのバカが死んじゃって
もう 3箇所で生まれるんですね
生まれが一人が死んだら
1箇所でしか生まれ変わらないでしょうに
それじゃあと で あの撮影はインドでやるんだから
インド人の機嫌を取らなくちゃいけない
それで一人がインドで生まれ変われるんです
映画はイギリス人作るんだから一人イギリス人でなければね
でも神様はアメリカ人だから一人アメリカ人で生まれ変わらないと
世界の神はそれで三人です
何のことなく計算的にわかるでしょうに
ありのままの事実で映画書いたならばもっといいのに
そこまで頭ができてないんですよ
物事をそのまま出しちゃえばね
問題は起きませんよ それは僕に能力が必要なんですよ
猫に猫と言うためには
だからまあ仏教の人々はそんなに
しかし 何かの映画の宣伝のために
アメリカの誰かですかね
仏像の上に乗っちゃって
写真撮って これでポスター作って
それはやめてくださいと
そしたら本人がちゃんと仏教の国に自分で行って謝って
それはもうあれはやり過ぎでしたと
それでは別にケンカも何もなく
向こうはポスターを出すのをやめたって
で こちらもまあ本人はもうわからないんだから
そんなことしたんであって
わかってやったわけじゃないんだからまあいいやと
それで無事解決でしょうに
それでアメリカ反対とかね
悪魔の国やとかね それはないんです
これで失礼でしょうと言う時ははっきり言いますよ
お前らのイエス師にこんなことやったらどうしますかとかね
ああ そういえばそうですねとかね
一緒に仏像と一緒に写真撮るのはいいんだけど
この体に乗って お釈迦様の首にまたがって
ということで まあそれはどうでしょうかな
やっぱりそれはまあいいんがないっていうことがわかって
それでまあすいませんで
いいよ いいよと で そうするとそれでそのもんでしょうね
世の中っていうのは だから仏教徒はいつでも頭が悪いというふうにやってられるんです
自爆テロでもやってないんだから
我々は自爆テロやりません
別に それで人を殺しちゃうと地獄に落ちるんだから
で ベトナムでアメリカ人がね
もうすごい平和のために人を殺せたでしょうね
で でもまあこれは良くないというか
あるお坊さんがね 自分で焼身自殺したんです
人を殺さないんです あんた方やってることはそういうもん
もう良くないんだと 反対しますよと
自分で焼身自殺 それでアメリカはあいつは病気だ
麻薬中毒やとかね あれやこれや誰も別に気にしなかった
もうどうぞ言ってくださいと
ちょこっと待ってみなさい
結果はどうなるのかと
結果どうなったんですかね？犬みたいに負けたでしょうに
だからといってベトナム人がアメリカ人に対して敵意持ってますかね？全然持ってないです
随分仲良くやってます
アメリカ ベトナムでいっぱいアメリカの会社が行って商売やってるわ
ベトナム人もあっちこっちでいるわ
アメリカではたくさん
ものすごいたくさんいますよ
だから仏教文化っていうのはそういう風に本当穏やかな文化なんですけどね
なかなか壊す 壊されるばっかりでね
だからこの我々 すごい簡単にこの天国に行けるんだ
そうすると天国に行ったら永遠だとかね
冗談じゃないんでしょうね
南無阿弥陀と言ったらもう極楽道があるんだとかね
なんてそんなことを言う
例えば 100円のおにぎりを買うためにも 110円払う
10円でしたっけ？ 105円でしたっけ
105円払わなくちゃ買えないのに
なんでそんなにすごい頭がいいんですかと聞きたいんですよ
この中でも朝から晩までバイトやったってもね
せいぜい 5,000円
6,000円しか一日もうかる収入はないし
では勝手に私は一日バイトしますから
100万円くれと 誰が上げるんですかね？別に理想的にはいいでしょうに
一日だけ朝から晩まで仕事をして
それで 100万円もらって
それからもうずっと 1ヶ月とか 2ヶ月間仕事をしないで遊びながらいて
またお金が終わっちゃった
ではバイトに行くぞと
そんな世界ある？だから現実を見ない方がすごくいいんですよ
100万儲かりたければ
もうバイトではもう儲かりませんよ
100万は いくらもう朝も夜も夜もずっと仕事したって
100万円はたまりませんよ
だっていろんなことにお金がもうもらうお金も全部なくなっちゃうんだから
それで何万だと言っただけで
永遠に極楽 極楽道っていうのはどういう考え方ですかね
これ真面目に信じること
浄土系のお坊さんたちに聞いたら
お坊さん 我々は信じてないんだよと
信者さんだと 頑張ってください
言ったらお坊さんたちもそんなアホな話あるわけないって
言ってますけど だからそんな甘くないんですよ
この世の中っていうのは
まあそれ努力に適した結果が得るんであって
努力にまるっきり値しない結果を得ると期待すること自体はね
それでイスラム教だったら
アッラーのみ唯一の神であって
他の神は信じませんと言ったら
もうイスラム教なんです
キリスト教だったら 水の中に放り込んでもらって
私の罪を悔い改めますとか
それで終わり それで天国は確保
永遠の天国 この前行ったイスラムの人も
あの まあ地獄はでも一回行ったらもう永遠だよと
質問すると それだったらね
いろいろ人間っていうのは悪いこともしますけど
それはまあ神様に言って許しをもらえば
いろいろ悪いことをしたんだから
まあお願いしますと それしなかったらもう終わり
もう二度とはそこからは上がりませんよと
それでえらいこと言う
でも仏教はね また生まれ変われると
そんなのはできません
できませんよと よく知ったつもりで言うんだけど
腹が立ったんですけども
あの連中に禁止だから他の考え方聞いてはいけませんだからね
だから仏教では一応罪を犯したっても
罪を償ってもらえば別なところに生まれ変わるということはバカバカしい思考であって
神を信じなかっただけでもう永遠な地獄やと
神を信じただけで永遠な天国やというのはすごい酔ったままだよ
考え方だそうです 道徳なし
ただ信じるか信じないかという
それでどんな法則でしょうかね
でも人間というのはそういう感じの完全にこの理屈にも論理にも因果法則にも科学にも何にも合わない
もう妄想観念 もうもうアラディンのランプの話でしょうね
それが事実真理だとということだからね
言いたいのはそんな甘くないんだよと
輪廻は 輪廻は微妙に計算
行為に適した結果が出る
もうどうにもならん それで宇宙の構成もやら
もう生命の流れやら もうこれはもうすごい巨大なもんだから
もう人間で二度と生まれ変われるということは
もうどんどん信じられないほど難しいことであって
こちらでこの地球でいくらかの人間がいるんだからといって軽々しく思ったらね
それはもうものは知らなすぎだけ
こう単義で考えることができれば
宇宙ひとつ現れて消えるってことはどうったことないんだと
たった一回だけでしょうと
そんなのはもう無数回に受けてますよと
無限に送るんだよと だから無限にビッグバンが起きたり
ビッグクランチ起きたり
また宇宙が現れたり消えたり
現れたり消えたりと そういう風にもうもうどこまででも続くんだよと
そこで知恵のある生命はすぐ逃げると
システムから だから天国に行ったんだからといって面白くないんですよ
そこで寿命終わったら
また別なところに行かなくちゃいけない
その時 人間の世界なかったならば
どうもどうも地獄の方に行かなくちゃいけないんです
どこでも人間いるわけじゃないんです
そこでこのエネルギーっていうのは
この何ストップで変化するんだから
死んだ瞬間で生まれ変わらないとね
ウェイティングリストはできません
例えば天国に生まれたとする
そこで寿命がもう終わって
次に人間に生まれようと思ったら
人間で生まれない状況があって
で 待ちましょうと あのあれ
なんて言いますか 銀行で引くでしょ
あれ 番号 番号引いて待ちましょう
輪廻の中でそんなのはないんです
何にストップで心が変化していますからね
だからそれを知ってる人はね
微妙でも輪廻には執着しないというね
今度生まれ変わったら何とかするとかね
冗談でしょうね 今度生まれ変わってから何こう経ってからでしょうかと
引き取りっこはなります
地獄に行ったらね もうかなり見込みがないんだけど
たとえ天国に行っても天国でも寿命は長いんだからね
天国の寿命は年代で言えますよ
一個より短い とにかく
年数 年数でアビダンマテキストを開けてみれば
全部寿命とかなんとか書いてあります
一番下の天界はまあ一日
百日は百年でしょうかね
もっと短いかな 一応計算すれば
人間の百年は向こうで一日だと
人間の百年は一日で それで三十日は一ヶ月間で
十二月十二ヶ月間は一年でということで
それでその天国の寿命はもう百二十歳とかね
百歳とかにしているんで
だから単純に計算できるでしょう
で なんで百歳二百歳というのはこれ感覚で理解したいんですよ
人間で百歳になってくると
もうもう終わりでしょう
もういくらなんでも 体がボロボロで
耳は遠くて だから誰も不思議がらないんですね
亡くなっても しかし 百年も経って亡くなると
かわいそうと誰も思わないでしょう
本当に幸せな人でしたとかね
ほとんど病気にもかからなかったと
元気でいてご飯も食べて亡くなったんだと
朝ご飯食べてちょっと調子が悪いのだから私は寝るぞ
横になるぞと横になったところでそのまま息を止めたと
幸せだな おばあちゃまはと言うでしょうね
だから幸福な死に方でしょ
だからそのイメージで
天界の神々の寿命も百年にしているんです
百年はちょっと計算違いますね
我々の百年じゃないんです
我々は百年は一日ですよと
向こうは それだったらもう食事するために一時間かかったらどれくらい時間かかるんでしょうかね
じゃあ計算してください
百年は一日だったらね
一時間というのは二十分の一でしょ
一日の二十四分の一でしょ
だから百年の二十四分の一でしょう
そんな難しくないでしょう
[笑い] 大まかに考えて年ですよね
え？ 大雑把に考えると年です
そうですね [笑い]だからまあ神はご飯食べるとこ四年かかると
[笑い]まあ楽しみではね
ある程度病気にならないしね
あの高血圧 糖尿病はないんで
天国では 心臓発作もないんです
病気にならないんですね
面白いでしょ なる要素がないんだから
この肉体を持ってないんだからね
一応 心臓もね 何もないんだからね
で だから物質はそれはそれをそんなに過酷を負いることはないんですけど
でも寿命終わったら死んじゃいます
それで神 天国になって人がこちらでね
今度生まれ変わったら瞑想してみましょうと言っても
それで一応いいことをしているんだから
悪いことしてないんだから
天国に行ったと仮定してください
死んでから戻れるのかと
そこで百年いてこちらに来ると地球があるんですかね
地球があるんですよ 一応
あるんだけど 誰がいるかと
それでまた修行できるのかと
ブッダの話聞ける 聞くことできるのかと
聞くチャンスあっても聞かない世界だから
修行するチャンスあっても言う通りにやりません
私が全て知ってるんだから
私の通りにやるぞという人間だから
そこで言う通りにやる気になるっていうことはね
いかに難しいかというね
だから一人の人でも瞑想成功したら
俺っていうのはもうストレートでオリンピックの金メダルを全部取ったような感じなんですよ
一人の人間が全ての試合に出て
ありえないぐらい難しいことなんです
だから そういう人々に頭を下げて拝んでみなさいと
頼ってみなさいよ 飲みたいていの精神の持ち主持ち主ってはないんですね
だから 生命導くならば
真理を発見した伊藤であるとかは誰にもできんということも言ってるし
だから輪廻の長さっていうのはそういうふうなことでいろいろ考えた方がよろしいんです
これはただ脅すために言ってるんじゃないんですよ
やっぱり宇宙スケールで物事を考えるとね
まあ時間の短っ 短いっていうことはね
簡単にわかるでしょう
そこでこの一余命なのに長く感じるんだというね
一余命というのは一キロだとすると
一キロぐらい歩くっていうのはどうったことないでしょうに
疲れるほどじゃないでしょ
ただ頭が悪いだけでね
例えば東京駅ででもね
ちょっと乗り換えてみてください
どれぐらい歩かせるのかと
東京駅で地下鉄に乗り換えるとか
あるいは JR でも何線でしたっけ？あれは地下でももう八百メートル歩かせるところあるでしょ？なんとか線に乗る場合は
あの 横須賀線とかですか
そうかな  外房線とかですか
深いとこ入ってますよね
すごく ディスランドとかいる
これでこちらの中央線から入って
じゃあディスランドでも行こうかなと思って
あの中で歩かせる距離はね
だから見事にだまされてね
1 キロ以上みんな歩かされてますよ
だから 1 キロ歩くっていうことは
まあどうってことはない
しかし 私はここでこれから 1 キロ行ったところで駅があります
そんな長いんですか？バスがないんですか？って聞くんですよ
普通そうでしょうに  1 キロのバスがあって
それで 200円取るんですね
バスの 東京からちょこっと離れたらそういうことでしょうね
駅のすぐそばにバスがあるんだけど
200円ですね 本当は歩いたって行けるんですけど
やっぱりもうもう遠いんだからね
バスで行こうかなとかいうことでするんです
なのに東京駅では平気で
歩いたりする だから だから怠け思考
非論理的な思考入っちゃうと 1 キロ歩けなくなっちゃって
もうバスに乗ろうとして 30 分待っている
歩けば 15 分 それでも何のことなく平気で駅から駅へ移動するともう
かなり歩くことになる
うん だからこのお釈迦様に説かれた通りに真理を発見してみると
すぐそばに気が狂うほど長い輪廻っていうのはすぐそこでストップなるんです
輪廻は天国と人間だけぐるぐる回っているならば
別にいいんじゃないかなと思ってますけどね
無限に人間にて人間にいくら苦労したって
せいぜい 100年で終わりますからね
勉強しながら来たのはそんなに長い間勉強するわけでもないしね
だからそれはまあまあ 10年くらい
それが頑張って それからなんとか
まあいいや もう死んじゃいますからっていうことね
それから天国だからとか
そんなもんじゃないんだからね
たまたま天国に行ったっても
それからどうするのか
その寿命終わったら 行くとこないんですよ
仏教で地獄っていう次元が人間の次元より下って意味なんです
いくらでもあるんです
だからノンステップだからね
輪廻転生は 死んだら生まれっていうのはね
すぐ隙間なく起こるんだからね
一旦落ちたらまた思考もやられちゃうしね
だから善なる思考を作ったりっていうことも難しくなるし
ほとんど不可能になるし
こちらの猫を見て考えたって
もう食べて寝るしかもう思考ないでしょう
それから何の訳もないんだけど
ずっと怯えて生活していて
それこそちょこっと精神的に喜ばせてあげて
自信つけてあげて もうあんた方も立派ではないかっていうそこまでちょこっと影響を与えるぐらいの力がないんだから
この飼っている人々に可愛がっている人々には
だからレベルが上がらないんですね
だから一旦落ちたらもう
そこから立ち上がるのはもうほとんど難しい
だからこの他宗教で言っているような子供騙しじゃなくてね
大変な世界なんです そこで一晩っていうのもどうったことないでしょうに
一晩徹夜するっていうことも
まだそれでどうったことはないんですよ
いくらでもやってるでしょう
しかし 何もなくて もう玄関であんたもうずっと六時から朝六時まで警備しなさいと待っていなさいと
言うと これがかなり厳しいんですよ
十二時間感じませんよ
ものすごいもう時間感じるんです
はい  そういうことで お釈迦様がこういう偈で言いたかって言いたがっているのは
輪廻脱出することっていうのはね
そんなに大したことじゃないんだと
ちょこっともう真理を理解しなさいよと
執着ぐらい捨ててみろと
無常を発見してみなさいと
無常しかないんだから
そんな発見が発見でいたっても
なんでそれしないのかと
百年に一回花が咲く植物もあります
知ってますかね え？別花美人じゃないんですけど
もうちょっと期間短いですね
でも滅多に花なんですけど
いろいろ植物あります
その寿命も百年に立った
大体百年ですね 百年で寿命が立つ場合ありますけどね
大きな花じゃなかったですか
花が咲くんです  滅多に見られないという
自分の国にはありますけどね
で 私の人生では二 三回ぐらいニュースで聞いたんですけどね
なんかどこかでもなんとか奇跡の花が咲いてるんだよと
それでみんな大勢行って見るんですよ
だってもうなかなか人生で一回しか見られないもんだからね
山であろうとも もう行ってみて
それで花が咲いてからその木はもうなくなりますけどね
スリランカで経典は葉っぱに書くでしょう
見たことはあります？その葉っぱは
でも うん？一応何かあったみたいな感じでしたありましたけどね
あの木なんです 花が咲かないんです
花が咲いちゃうともう
まあいっぱいありますからね
それぞれ見られないわけでもないんですけど
で そんなものを言ってるわけじゃないんでしょうね
みんな 必ずそれを見なくちゃいけないんだとかね
時々彗星も来るでしょう
二三十年に一回とかね
みんなその彗星見なくちゃいけないと言ったっても
ちょうどその時の人間しか見られませんし
またそれはもう地球上どこでも見られるわけじゃないでしょうに
見られる日にちがあって
そこで空が曇ってるとまた見られないでしょうに
そんな稀なことを言ってるわけじゃないんだよ
お釈迦様は 無常を見なさいと
全て無常ですから 無常以外何もないんだから
なんでそれ発見できないんですかね
相当無知でしょうに 皆様に絨毯というものを見てくださいと言うと
すごい難しいですかね
そんなこと言ってもね
これ結構大変でしょう？とか言うと
ものすごい馬鹿でしょ
やっぱりいつか見たいんですねとかね
今度暇があったら見てみましょうとかね
何のことを言ってるんですかね
今我々は絨毯の上に座ってるんだからね
だからそんなものでしょうね
無常を発見するっていうことは
だから愚か者にはならないっていうことはそういうことなんです
それでこのいろんな宗教の考え方でものすごく騙されてるんです
一つではなくて もう全ての宗教ってのは人を騙してるんですよ
すっごく嘘を言っても死んだら成仏できますとかね
天国ですよと 葬式でどんなバカが死んじゃっても
天国でなんとかとかね
どこにいるか誰もわかるとわかるもんじゃないでしょうに
もうこれすごく無知な世界ですね
本当にもう みんな弔辞を言うんですね
死んだ人に向かって もうテレビでしか見たことがないんですけど
もう見ていられないんで
この馬鹿騒ぎさっていうのはね
だからそういうことを長い間やっちゃうと
もう文化的に遺伝的にこの無知になっちゃうんですよ
試しに自分の国の葬式なんか見ることできればね
全然質素なんです 決して死んだ人は天国に行ってるとは言わないんです
いくらその人のことを褒めても
それは言いません 誰も
最近の人々もよく喋りますよ
あれはもう何か何大会でスピーチ大会ですよ
私はだいたい葬式に作ってる名前はね
スピーチ大会やと みんな親戚代表して一人が喋るわ
仕事の会社から来て一人が喋るわで
何かなにかの組織に入ってたらそちらの代表が来て喋るわ
村の村を代表して一人が喋るわ
お寺から喋るわ またその人は他のお寺とも行ったこと
知り合いがいたならば
そのお坊さんたちも来て
またもう喋るわ 大体二時に始めたら四時四時半五時まで喋ってるんです
これがイライラするんだから
もう何とかしなくちゃあかんと
私はスピーチ大会だと
スピーチコンテストだと
私のお寺である場合は
この最初の法事のところはお寺でやらなくちゃいけないんだからね
私がいると 私はではスピーチ大会をやってみろということで
私は喋るんです すっごい短い時間で言ったら
誰にももうこれから言葉出て出なくなっちゃうんです
何喋ればいいかわからなくなっちゃうんです
で もうこれはもう人の知識
もうくだらない知識を回顧するのはそんなにどうったことはないんだけどね
でお坊さんたちもいろんなところから上げて待ち構えて喋らせていると
もうこれって嫌だな こんな長い時間こちらでいたくないなと思っちゃうと
私は自分が説法するんです
それは見事にコンパクトで
まあまあ十分は飛ばせません
いくらなんでも それからまあなんかいい結構結構結構ですと
お坊さんちはそれではアウトで
それで最近の人たちはどうせ喋らなくちゃいけないんですけど
まあ大事なことだけ言って
それで終わっちゃうんです
時々私の説法だけで全て終了した場合もあります
みんなやめる まあそれはいろいろ能力ですからね
一応もうもう一旦こちらに話が来たら
もう誰ももう耳は傾いてくれないでしょうかね
人はね 本人の頭にあった情報も全部死んでいるし
言うだろうと思う論点も出さず全部潰しておくんで
最初から で 私は早く帰りたいんで
そんなくだらない で まあそういう誰が喋ってもみんな言うのは
この人はもうどういうことをして
どういう生き方をして
どういう人間関係を持って
どんな人間でいたのかということはもう言うんであって
天国にいるおじい様もあれこれとかね
紙に書いて読み上げるってことはないんです
だからこの理性的で知識から脱線しないっていうことを結構しっかりと守ってますよ
あちらはただの人間ですけどね
天国に待っていてくださいとかないんです
今もう亡くなったおじいさんと一緒に喜んでいるでしょう
おばあさんが天国でとかね
それはない だからこの
そういういろんな宗教の世界でね
人をすっごく全ての宗教がね
人を騙してるんですよ
だからまあ生きることというのはなんてありがたいこと
それから天国もあるでしょうとかね
そんな世界じゃないんですよ
輪廻っていうのは わからなかったら
まあいろんな科学者が書いてる宇宙のことでも勉強してみれば
生命なことを言っておいて
宇宙のことぐらいはそれなりにいろいろ推測ばっかしなんですけど
まあ推測でもいろんなデータに基づいた推測するんだからね
考えたらどうですかね
地球で生命誕生 してどれぐらい時間がかかっているのかとか
人間が現れてどれぐらい時間がかかっているのかとか
そういうことを見ても
宇宙のドラマっていうのはそんな美しいものじゃないっていうことがわかるでしょうに
時間的にはものすごい時間でしょうに
そこで時間というものも成り立たないとホーキングさんとか言ってるでしょうに
時間は相対的であると
ヒストリーオブタイムという本を書いてますからね
時間にも歴史があるんだと
いつ現れていつ消えるのかというヒストリーがあるんです
普通は時間は無限ということになるでしょう
そうじゃないんです 宇宙的に考えると
すべての人間の概念も時間も科学も全部終わりになるところがあるんだよと
何も成り立たない 法則も
今まで科学者が発見している真理も
すべて何一つ成り立たない時があるんだよと
だから心のことをわからなくても
大体物質のことから考えたっても
宇宙のドラマがその美しくてたまらんものじゃないんです
それよりひどいんですよ
心のドラマは だからこのずっと騙されてきたんだから
嘘は正しいと信じてきたんだから
誰も生命の脆さには気づかないんですね
そこはすごくハンディになっちゃうんですよ
だから愚か者にはなりということになるんですね
[背景音楽]